welcome to all of you to our eighth
session believe it or not it is eighth
session wow it's going fast for me I
don't know how fast it's going for you
but it's an eighth session that we have
together on faith and violence we have
two guests with us and after my
introductory remarks they will be
introduced and will follow our regular
procedure let me just say those that
this association between faith and
violence especially during 911 but in
other places as well has brought to
attention the importance of faith for
globalization processes in general
importance of faith in public affairs
brought attention to it not to made it
important conflicts as we've read also
early on in that session are often now
justified less on ideological grounds
but on religious grounds and
globalization as our main teacher the
main kick Oh to whom I'm sidekick you
have to come up with a better word for
this what is a person to whom I'm a
psychic to me as Tony Blair often says
globalization pulls people together and
religion separates them and in an
interdependent world disturbed
stabilizing effects of conflicts based
on localized particular loyalties have
important impact broader than just that
particular locale but what is precisely
the link between religion and
contemporary violence we have examined
some of that early on first session when
we discussed about nine nine eleven as
the case study is religion a factor the
main factor proxy for something else and
we've gone through a wide variety of
options now we're returning to this
topic freshly maybe with a set of
slightly different questions I think our
assumption can be said that it is that
religion is an important factor but
certainly we've I think generally agreed
that all mono causal explanation of such
large cases of scale cases of violence
as often have been the case in the
recent history our suspect but then
question is that we've discussed in this
session that we read materials about our
fates by their nature violent if fates
are associated with violence what's the
character of that relationship and then
if fates are not so to say by nature
pre-prom them to be violent what are the
conditions under which they morph and
possibly become violent how do faiths
interact with other factors in the
context of violence and what are the
consequences for peacemaking why does it
matter somebody asked that question in
the during one of our sections so we
figure this one out why does it why does
it matter I think that's a very
important question to address some of
these issues we have looked at set of
readings as well as case studies in two
experts are here with us but before they
come and talk let me just sketch what I
thought that we roughly read our fates
by nature violence violence some of our
readings at least one of our readings
suggest that well no not suggested
strenuously argued right that religions
are violent know that religions kill all
right that's the Christopher Hitchens
and it's not quite sure exactly what the
nature of that argument was except kind
of a string of powerful anecdotes but I
think it may be summarized but it may be
summarized let me live in food either
it's not like I was trying not to put
him down to I'm not gonna go not too
hard on him but I guess I'm not quite
succeeding but
I think that the argument is probably
summarized in this quotation that he is
from John Stuart Mill right that
religion is a kind of form of mental
delusion a form of untruthfulness right
and at the same time that it is that it
does constitute a great moral evil now
we're and also Jergens Myers book terror
in the mind of God and their religion
ends up being somewhat more ambivalent
and contains the seeds of ireland's it
contains also seeds of peace religious
imagination says Jergens Meyer always
has had the propensity to absolute eyes
and to project images of cosmic war
always has had right at the same time
every religious tradition has projected
images of tranquility and peace and has
resources of that sort and then for him
the solution to this problem lies in the
recognition that religions give spirit
to public life and pro and provides a
beacon for moral order that's the very
end of his book but at the same time he
argues it needs kind of a temper of
enlightened rationality to protect it
from the worst dimensions of itself now
for today's session we did not reread
Martin David Martin but I thought that
David Martin's idea of religions as
having a certain kind of repertoire that
can be played in various registers
certain things for ground at the others
background and certain things
transformed also as the history
progresses might be a very fruitful
fruitful one and can be put along the
lines of these these two if we
categorize possible responses and then
he if he's idea if we go with his notion
we wouldn't be searching for something
like the essence of individual religion
and asking whether it's violent or not
as in the case of jergens Meyer partly
right we wouldn't do that for all
religions in aggregate also I think this
is a German smart thesis as well with
instead asking a question identifying a
configuration of element in the
repertoire
which at the given time go one way or
the other and I think we read something
to the of this sort as we were reading
our materials I think especially kind of
debate between a classical tradition or
classical configuration of religious
repertoire and certain forms of
distortions and one way to analyze these
is to look at differentiate between kind
of external conditions that influence
the way repertoire is played and then
what happens internally to the
repertoire what happens to religion
inside right and in terms of external
conditions we've studied the case and
we'll discuss it much more Sri Lankan
Buddhism paradox of a Buddhist monk who
takes up arms external conditions if Tom
be a is to be followed is a perceived
threat to religion religion of Buddha
threat to culture language and culture
of saying la's and thread to a nation
sovereign territory which is motherland
of Sri Lanka and then a certain sense of
rights to participate in in the politics
and then protecting the rights of or
order or the sons of soil from various
out outside influences in the case of
serbian church i think something similar
can be some similar kinds of steps can
be can be retraced and as we were
reading also for today the the the the
colleague abdul fuddled right I'm
missing I'm sorry I'm missing his is
this very fine piece which I'm blanking
on his name he differentiated quite
quite compellingly I think between a
kind of classical tradition with moral
vision given to humanity and kind of
civilizational a mission and contrast
that in the context of colonialist and
modernist movements opposition to the
West as a form which that that religion
takes and a kind of struggle for power
and then war generating
ideology so those were some of the
external forces which play religious
registers in different way and then
possible we can think about internal
conditions within each each religion and
one way to think about it is well there
are lots of folks who simply don't
follow the teaching of a particular
religion who don't care too much about
the teaching they identify with it but
they don't care about religious teaching
or I have tried to distinguish in the
text that was your optional reading
knowing that I had the right to make you
listen to this idea whether whether you
want to read it or not right text which
was your optional reading was I've tried
to distinguish between what I called
thick and thin religiosity and I'm
partly building on the use of taking tin
by gears and especially by Michael
Walzer thick religiosity is a certain
moral vision of religion embedded in an
account of self social relations and the
good you've heard me speak about that
and that embedded in a larger
interpretation of reality and then that
combined with a certain tradition of
argumentation about this all religious
traditions are not static and they're
not internally kind of simply making
claims rather there there are debates
going on across the lines in our period
of time and then a sense of certain
connection that gives to the to the
ultimate sense of a holy and the
imperative of self-transcendence those
will be some of the elements of this
thick religiosity but then what happens
often is thinning out of religion to
what could be described as cultural
resource alright and what ends are being
discarded is that you can see that int
ambience article and many other
instances also but ends up being
discarded is this broad moral vision
what ends up being discarded is the long
and lengthy tradition on ruiz of Reason
debate about the goods that that
religion represent and what you end up
having is something retained sense of
all tennessee and of the sacred and
that's sacred then shrouds the mundane
causes we
with an aura of of sacred legitimizes
and motivates for action but what guides
the action doesn't stem from this moral
vision but rather stems form all sorts
of causes which have attached themselves
to religion or for which religion
provides legitimation so both external
influences and kind of internal
transformation of religions takes place
if religions are to be employed in IA
invite to to sanction and to motivate to
to violence roughly that's some of the
reading at least what we have done and
it and and the way maybe of thinking or
at least suggesting framework to think
about relationship between religion and
violence but now it's my time to give
room to HL as I have been instructed to
call Lisa and he's asked us to call him
HL his early research interests were
fashioned by three factors in the
context of growing up in Sri Lanka first
the Buddhist rituals that were all
around him stimulated him to explore the
meaning that these rituals help in Sri
Lanka second Sri Lanka was going through
radical social change during his
lifetime third Sri Lanka was groping for
identity and economic security in the
post-colonial era his work represents a
critical examination of the themes and
social processes arising from the kind
of social context that we've just
mentioned which he says is commonplace
in the
world social change emergence from
colonialism in the search for national
identity and economic security have
brought out a great deal of idealism but
much more turbulence confusion and human
suffering says his specialties our
religion and politics socialism
classical social theory Human Rights
democracy and free market economy f'nor
nationalism cinema arts and popular
culture and of his many many
publications his most recent are 2001
Buddhist monks and ethnic politics in
anthropology today and the work of kings
and the new buddhism in sri lanka
published by university of chicago he
serves as professor emeritus in the
anthropology department of the
University of Virginia thank you for
being with us thank you essentially nice
to be here and thank you for inviting me
but let me I know that I have only 15
minutes and so your professor has all
you told me that you you familiar with
Sri Lanka so I'm not going to take any
time talking about but just to remind
you if we should refresh your minds I
will just mention that Sri Lanka is an
island in the Indian Ocean and he said
it's it's 25,000 square mile which is
the size of West Virginia and the
majority ethnic group and the population
is about 20 million majority ethnic
group is single e-sourcing holla about
seventy percent and they're Buddhists
mostly the largest minority are the
thermals there about fifteen percent and
they are mostly Hindus I say mostly
because they are both among the tunnels
and Leasing least there are Christians
and the Christian population is about
seven percent and about another seven
percent of Muslims and a peculiar
feature of the categorization of people
in religions in Sri Lanka is to which is
an inn I think Sri Lanka editor from the
British is that Muslims are considered
somehow an ethnic group rather than a
religious group and of course the it is
understood that they are also ethnic but
I mean real religious but they're
classified under
my groups since the 16th century Sri
Lanka or salon as it was known to the
Western as until nineteen seventy-two
has been under some form of colonial
European domination first the Portuguese
then the dutch held the maritime regions
of the island until the arrival at the
British at the dawn of the nineteenth
century unlike the Portuguese and the
Dutch the British were able to bring the
entire island under their control and
held it until nineteen forty eight and
Christianity arrived with the Portuguese
and the large majority of the Christians
in Sri Lanka are Catholics and the
Reformed churches were introduced by the
Dutch and the British in 1915 there were
riots that targeted Muslims which were
forcefully put down by the British
government it is instructive to remember
that it is not a religion per se that
provoked the violence against the
Muslims but the economic dominance in
trade which which the rising single
business classes wanted to curb economic
self-interest in the form of competition
for in education jobs and business is at
the root of most of the recent violence
as well as as I see as I say the subject
it's important for us to remember this
when we talk about Buddhist violence
most media reports on violence in Sri
Lanka in with the statement that the
single is our Buddhist and tamanna
Hindus which suggests religious conflict
this is not the case at all there is no
crusade or jihad in Sri Lanka religious
violence in Sri Lanka is rather an
attempt by certain sections of the
population to use certain traditional
ideas about society polity and
well-being to further their individual
and class interest if the Sri Lankan
conflict is primarily economic why is it
so often considered religious why is it
Buddhist violence what is it that is
Buddhist about it what connection does
it have with Buddhism for an answer we
might look at what we might call the
paradigm of ideal society in the
dominant pre-colonial Sri Lankan
worldview this paradigm was first
articulated in the National Chronicle
known as the Maha
1500 years ago the island of Sri Lanka
according to this paradigm is the island
of righteousness because it has been
foreseen by the Buddha that it is in Sri
Lanka that his Dharma or message would
shine it follows that good government
has as its first responsibility the
nourishment and protection of Buddhism
is a particular destiny of the single
ethnic group symbolized by the Buddhist
King to carry out this responsibility
the exclusivity and responsibility or
the exclude exclusivity of this
responsibility and the implied exclusive
ownership of the island by the majority
single ethnic group is expressed in a
myth in which the good the miraculously
draws near the shores of Sri Lanka a
faraway land mass frightens the
aboriginal that is non signal
inhabitants to fleeing into this land
mass and then returns it to its original
geographical location now you know it is
a clearly clever myth because it is
ethnic cleansing but nonviolent and
because you couldn't possibly involve
the Buddha in a violence so you you must
have some other way of ethnic cleansing
when the when Buddhism's will being in
longevity I assured nothing everything
else that is important like health
happiness prosperity follow
automatically this means that the
Buddhism should be protected at any cost
what we have here is an irrevocable
linking of signal ethnicity Buddhism
kinship and a territory as that that is
one and indivisible to learn more about
the relevance of this paradigm for
violence in Sri Lanka we must look at
the work of the early 20th century
Reforma anagha rica dharmapala turbo
Paulo placed the blame for the country's
poverty and overall social and moral
decline squarely on the colonial rule
and Christian missionary activity in his
view pre-colonial Lanka was a happy
bountiful and glorious utopia of the
single a Buddhist this demi paradoxical
state was made possible by the moral
purity of the single a Buddhist people
rising from the
failing adherent to the five Buddhist
precepts and otherwise following a
Buddhist way of life colonial rule and
Christian missionaries disrupted this
idyllic society by introducing foreign
food drink and clothing and customs and
mores that let people to violate the
Buddhist precepts the monks roll the
army pal argued was to help the people
overcome their poverty and degradation
by guiding them in morality as well as
discipline economic activity and
restoring to them they are glorious
erstwhile identity by reviving Buddhism
and national culture and exhort the
monks to traverse the countryside and
perform this national service it is
quite obvious that this model can only
work with a homogeneous society where
all citizens belong to a single
ethno-religious group or where any
outsiders must willingly or unwillingly
accept majority hegemony and subordinate
or erase all together their own identity
but social changes brought about by
colonial contact with the modern West
have shattered the relevance of this
paradigm and changed it from being a
more or less harmless periodic
legitimation of the status quo into a
source of majority hegemony and
operation of the minorities in the
pre-colonial state despite the
homogenizing rhetoric of the paradigm
the ground reality contained mechanisms
of incorporating the minorities and
their cultures the paradigm in other
words was a fiction that provided for a
rhetoric of exclusivist identification
Buddhism and single ethnicity to coexist
with a parent PAP with pragmatic
arrangements to deal with what we today
call diversity in contrast in the new
society brought about by colonial wrote
the paradigms conception of protecting
Buddhism and the nation took new meaning
as a propagandist slogan for power
seeking elites and influence peddling
interest groups in particular with the
incremental introduction of the right to
vote starting about 1910 culminating in
universal suffrage in 1931 slogan so
protecting Buddhism and
become became excellent platforms for
politicians intent on seeking political
office electro love running the
grandiloquent themes of the paradigm now
spelt out as religion nation identity
ethnicity language national culture and
the splendor of the past could be used
by politicians to appeal to appeal to
appeal to primordial sentiments and get
elected to power these themes were put
to the test in a conscious and organized
manner for the first time in the general
election of 1956 and they emerged with
flying colors as winners Buddhist monks
were at the forefront of this election
and they became along with the olay
counterparts a powerful lobby for
religion nationalist agenda for for a
religion as a nationalist agenda that in
effect placed disabilities on the
minorities in their pursuit of
opportunities in education state
employment and the professions and
business enterprise the most disabling
of these are number one the elevation of
the majority language as the one
official language and number two the
restriction of school admission to the
minority children by resort to a process
called standardization the tamil
minority was also greatly alienated by
the government programs of peasant
resettlement in regions they considered
to be to be their traditional homelands
starting with nonviolent protests and
civil disobedient the tamils responded
with increasing militancy especially
after their struggle changed hands from
a generation of educated elite
politicians to armed and religion
relatively uneducated you three bells
among groups of rush rebels the ltte or
the Tigers became preeminent and their
attacks and the attempt of the Sri
Lankan security forces to contain them
have led to disastrous Savile Row in
which an estimated seven seventy
thousand have been killed and a million
displaced before concluding this I would
like to make two general points first
when we talk about Buddhist violence we
generally mean violence committed
against the minority Tamils by the
buddhist-majority but since the 1970s we
have seen the rise of a violent
moment of Buddhist youth known as the
jvp especially in the second
insurrection about the eighteen nineteen
eighty nine they committed unspeakable
atrocities on fellow Buddhist a strug
including targeted Buddhist monks the
single a Buddhist dominated State
responded in kind these developments
along with with the terrorist attacks of
the ltte combined with a general decline
in the underlying moral anchors of the
social order have contributed to a
broader culture of violence in a
devaluation of human life a proper
understanding of Buddhist violence must
consider this broad overall decline in
the value foundations of the society the
second point I want to make is of some
more direct relevance to your concerns
about globalization where the
globalization pulls diverse people
together or pushed them apart in a civil
towards it it seems common sense at the
lee at least to our Western economic
rationality that the free exchange that
is at the center of globalization does
being people together I think this is a
fundamental insight of the sociologist
Emile Durkheim when he talked about
organic solidarity in his well-known
work the division of labor in society
but the sri lankan case seems to suggest
that this could work both ways data from
other societies illustrated and this
ambivalence towards globalization as
well religion nationalism in Sri Lanka
is deeply distrustful of foreigners and
foreign cultural and consumer items this
is the antithesis of globalization it
includes the denunciation of foreign
ngos which are assumed to be pro tamil
and therefore part of a conspiracy to
divide the country large-scale
globalization in sri lanka began with
the free-market policies of the 1977
government which is associated with the
indian military intervention
intervention of 1987 which is a black
mark for globalization the religion
nationalists are also opposed to number
one imported popular entertainment like
and Bollywood films and they opposed to
fast foods like mcdonald's and coca-cola
and Kentucky Fried Chicken and so on to
and they are opposed to people
celebrating Valentine's Day some of
these opposition could take violent form
as when they exploded a bomb at the
heavily subscribed open-air concert in
which to volley would heartthrobs of
millions shahrukh khan and pate isn'ta
were to perform a killing to young
people and injuring many and i can also
use the example the vandalism cause into
2004 buddhist murals done by a young
dutch woman in sri lankan temple and i
have an entire paper on the subject and
i'd be happy to talk more but later on
the plus side Sri Lanka has a business
community which welcomes globalization
and it has periodically express itself
responsibly on matters of grave public
concern like the state of law and order
good governance and the need for a
national consensus over here in more
time how many of you oh okay yes I can
do it into means I i just want to
mention one thing about conversions
there is one of the one the grievances
as a Buddhist clergy and the right-wing
Buddhist you know establishment in
general is this thing called conversion
they are called unethical conversions
and these are conversions actually of
the evangelicals so there is no real
opposition to the established church the
Catholic Church going back 500 years and
of course people in Silicon don't quite
distinguished between these things they
think cathode is it Catholicism and the
Reformed churches and the event it's all
sort of equated of course there are some
sections of people are knowledgeable but
but but I want to say is that in fact I
won't quote very well-known Buddhist
monks called a whirlpool Rahul or some
of your familiar is his name Rahul told
me in one of his interviews
that the people who are not opposed to
Christianity the people would have
welcomed Christianity had it been at it
come by itself rather than as as as a
companion to colonial to imperialism and
and Dharma pal this great signal a
Buddhist propagandists has written in
one of his books writings he he has no
problem with the Christianity his
problem with the missionaries because
they were humiliating him they were they
were not only him but his culture the
early mission is there you know this
insensitivity of the missionaries is
something that is I mean if they're
smart they could be a little bit more
you know and anyway the Dharma I would
just quote this this wonderful a
statement of the Apollo he says he talks
very here adoringly actually of the
gentle Nazarene meaning Jesus Christ but
what his problem was with not with the
gentle Nazarene but but but the
missionaries and thank you thank you
very much I'm sure we will return to
many aspects of of this paper one thing
that I want to highlight which which we
haven't taught too much about and that's
the question of evangelism it is one of
the very important issues in
muslim-christian relations it is Hindu
Christian relations and then number of
other ways in which that relationship
those relationships are tens on account
of a certain understanding of evangelism
of Dawa of spreading one's bathe and
that too is part and parcel of our
globalized setting that needs to be kind
of named as an as an issue now it is my
honor to introduce to you Peter cosmic I
thought as is the custom our guests will
be introduced by somebody else than
myself and so I came completely
unprepared and Neil the Magnificent told
me that's my punishment for not being
present at at a meeting of TAS but it's
a it's a pleasant it's a pleasant duty
Peter I've known Peter for about 35
years now and it's tough to do for me to
describe Peter maybe because I know him
so well do you you know maybe that's
really irrelevant whether I do or not I
think that I do and therefore all the
implications of knowing you will apply
in this particular case just because I
think that I do well Peter is peter is
an educator a founder of educational
institutions of higher learning in
former Yugoslavia he is also a public
intellectual inserting himself in major
ways in the politics and broader culture
I think not so much politics of of
Croatia and more broadly he's a
humanitarian who has worked long and
hard hours seen unspeakable things
throughout the war in former Yugoslavia
and its aftermath he's also respected
and well known worldwide evangelical
leader who has capacity to bridge to
other traditions in extraordinary ways
so that he can be main main speaker in
the world a world council of churches
event as well as in evangelical events
and that's one of the things that has
kind of characterized Peters career
namely ability to do span things cold
things together which otherwise tend to
fall fall apart now I have a kind of
more personal relationship to him peter
is my well prepared Peter set me on to
the course for ill or for good set me on
to the course of doing theology or being
intellectually interested at all because
time he was dating my sister to whom he
is married right now hopefully dating
yeah so it's been much pleasure that I
used to be their coach I must say that
my sister will crucify me if I know well
can I thank you let us love you're very
kind I think I'll stand not for your
sake but for my sake because I'm still
dealing with jet lag I have just come
from the Balkans two nights ago and it's
wonderful to be with you here at Yale I
understand this is an interdisciplinary
seminar now let me start with my own
background which will illustrate what we
are talking about how many of you have
traveled Central and southeastern Europe
quite a few it's a real class okay all
right so if you visualize the map you're
coming from Germany by car through
Austria and you want to go to Greece
okay you enter former yugoslavia in a
place where i was born called slovenia
you exited from the slavic macedonia to
go into greece and in between you have
croatia you have serbia your bosnia you
have montenegro you have the autonomous
what used to be autonomous regions of
kosovo in the south and of voivode ina
in northern Serbia now Yugoslavia has
been called the India of Europe more
than once because of this ethnic and
religious makeup now here I am i was
born in slovenia on the border with
Austria and Hungary maybe I should do a
little map because about one-third of
you didn't try now one should not really
film this map
you are well there's Italy don't ask me
about the shoe there remember your high
school geography Austria and then comes
hungry and we go down like this romania
and we've got bulgaria and we've got
albania and we've got grease okay and so
you have slovenia up here and you have
croatia which looks like this and you
have bosnia here in the center croatia
slovenia and we have Serbia here
montenegro have you heard of montenegro
kosovo you must have heard because we've
got a distinguished lady here from
Kosovo or cassava and Macedonia okay i
was born in slovenia i have lived in
serbia in belgrade for two years I've
lived in Surrey when Banja Luka in
Bosnia I am a citizen of Croatia so when
people who are well informed like you
are here this they say wait a moment
that's the part of the world where they
have reinvented ethnic cleansing at the
end of the 20th century where people
have been frantically searching for
their ethnic identity identity as you
are finding out in this course is a big
word we live in a world of warring
identities and others have been
fanatically fighting for their ethnic
purity so who are you actually aren't
you
a little confused if anybody would think
that I might be confused I take a little
soft revenge I bring my wife last I into
the picture because I met blasta you
know college in Germany where she came
from Serbia although she's Croatian
although her father scoff German and her
mother is fully check and so the answer
in the words of paraphrase of the words
of Robert Frost would be don't worry
about me I'm not confused I am just well
mixed like some of you now della
graphically just a few points November
1989 1 million people are gathered in a
place called Ghazi missed on celebrating
the 600th anniversary of the Kosovo
battle 1 million people national TV in
all of these republics is carrying the
event mr. slobodan milosevic of course
is the principal speaker and among other
things because Yugoslavia by the way a
compound youg South Slavic people's like
all of these plus 2 million Albanians
Yugoslavia is in a crisis and mr.
Milosevic says among other things this
Yugoslavia sees we will resolve by
constitutional means or
extra-constitutional means and then he
says this crisis we will resolve by
peaceful means or other means you don't
need to be very intelligent to interpret
what the other means are as an option to
peaceful means at that time I was
writing for a secular progressive weekly
and I wrote an article and I said we
have heard the rhetoric of war wars
begin with words the hand of the
potential killer I did not name him he's
in the air somebody better stop him
before the innocent people suffer now
this college is in oceak
here and we had students from all over
the place and some neighboring countries
and two of my Serbian students organized
the protest against me the professor and
the principal of the school and they
said well you have pronounced our
president a killer and I said I I didn't
I said potentially wars begin with words
okay I wish there was some kind of an
international regulatory body which
would prevent hate speech before it
becomes hate crime which would prevent
the abuse of religion and
instrumentalization of religion for
violent means before violence is
committed let's this is no vember 89
okay five months later elections are
held in the different Republic's
Slovenia Croatia Serbia Bosnia
Montenegro and Macedonia and you have
all of the Republic's except for Serbia
and Montenegro elect the Democratic
pro-western governments some of them
nationalistic because the rhetoric from
Belgrade coming from Milosevic and his
comrades became increasingly bellicose
triumphal istic but mr. Milosevic and
the president of Montenegro skillfully
controlled and manipulated the media and
they were able to stay in the office so
you have two capitals of two Republic's
that want to keep on to the old
socialist Federation of Yugoslavia and
their privileges and the army is on
their side once they find out that that
is impossible they change the rhetoric
and they move from the socialist
Federation of Yugoslavia to creating
greater Serbia okay now and that leads
us to the beginning of the words you've
read about
it aetna cleansing the abuse of religion
Bosnian Muslims who were victims in more
ways than one can describe mass rapes
ethnic cleansing barbarities rebel needs
a slaughter of 7,000 men and so on
bosnian muslims were first attacked by
the serbian minority supported from
serbia and they the aggression was
almost like a medieval aggression
medieval Crusades with a sword in one
hand and the cross in another when
crowds were seventeen percent of the
population of Bosnia soul and Croatia
Catholics that international community
will do nothing they said well we better
grab some land and so you had Croat
Catholics and Serbian Orthodox fight
nominal Muslims in Bosnia this is the
heart of the problem this is the prelude
to Kosovo which is our youngest nation
we created seven eight new nation states
we hold the world record I think and
Kosovo is the last one Montenegro is
only two years two years old all of that
started with that speech in Kosovo in
November 89 and then with the abuse of
religion and finally you have these
these sick political leaders with sick
ambitions former communists they have
discovered the power of religious
symbols and they are instrumental izing
religious symbols they are using
religious rhetoric and so you hear
language like heavenly Serbia and some
old myths are resurrected you hear
similar sack realization of the
political and ethnic entities like when
you hear the language of the holy Russia
just watch if Russia is holy it's like
holy inquisition or holy Crusades and so
on because if it is called you cannot
touch it there is already a triumphalism
and militancy in the very religious
description of who you are and what you
doing although there is no tick
religiosity there and we can we can
discuss that later I have been warned
that my time is about up I've tried to
work I've tried to talk okay you see one
needs to see that in in in the context
communist ideology singular all across
Eastern Europe has been replaced by
nationalistic ideologies plural
nationalistic ideologies have been and
are supported by the resurgence of the
old national religions whatever was was
suppressed under communism of course
once the lid was off started exploding
one was nationalism you know the comedy
set up to build the international
workers of the world unite you have
nothing to lose but your chains so
ethnicity was not that important Russian
more or less were dominant in the Soviet
Union serves were quite dominant in
former Yugoslavia and so you had the
explosion of nationalism and explosion
of religion and they found each other
again in a very uncritical fashion and
so religion and ethnicity are now used
by political leaders to fight the others
those who are different we can mention
Kosovo later because that is also
nominally nominally Muslim as was
bozniak Islam nominally Muslim but now
there is an radicalization of the
Islamic option taking place because
there is a radicalization of Serbian
orthodoxy or Croat Catholicism in the
neighboring countries thank you for your
patience